Друзі, всім привіт! У Німеччині є такий жарт: щойно зустрічаються троє німців,
вони засновують об'єднання - німецькою "ферайн". У ФРН існує понад 600 тисяч об’єднань
на будь-який смак. Ця серія присвячена саме їм.
Німці об’єднуються заради допомоги іншим, щоб займатися спортом,
довкола певного захоплення, аби обмінюватися досвідом і знаннями.
Найстарішими об’єднаннями у Німеччині є стрілецькі клуби. Їхні традиції сягають ще 12-го століття.
Тоді гуртувалися для самозахисту, сьогодні стрільців об’єднує спортивний азарт.
Загалом у Німеччині налічується 90 тисяч спортивних клубів. Завітаємо до дзюдоїстів
района міста Бонн Бад Годесберг. Засновник школи дзюдо Koдокан Кано Дзіґоро
зі світлини на стіні суворо спостерігає за поєдинком.
Поруч - назва клубу з обов'язковими літерами Е та V.
Літери "Е" та "V" в назві означають "зареєстроване об’єднання".
Це юридична форма об'єднання, що регулюється цивільним кодексом.
Це дозволяє нам як юридичній особі укладати контракти із членами об’єднання,
причому ми продовжуємо діяти як юридична особа і надалі - незалежно від того,
приходять до нас нові члени чи вони йдуть від нас.
Чітке і докладне пояснення - доволі очікувано, адже керівник дзюдо-клубу -
ще й  професор і доктор юридичних наук. Марван Гамдан має чорний пояс,
дзюдо займається вже 42 роки - з 5-річного віку.
Це наші тренери. Це Соня. Другий дан, чорний пояс, вже десять років бере участь
у національному чемпіонаті. Дуже технічна борчиня.
Александер має 5 дан. Наші нові тренери не лише навчають дітей дзюдо,
а й проводять виховну роботу.
Об’єднання нараховує 860 учасників, більшість з яких - діти.
Щомісячний внесок становить 22 євро.
Я працюю тут безкоштовно. Це неоплачувана робота. Моя основна робота - викладач в університеті.
Члени клубу раз на рік обирають свого шефа. Нині це я. У нас значний оборот грошей,
майже як у великій фірмі, у формі членських внесків, у нас своя власна будівля,
ми маємо найманих працівників, тож на мені обов’язків, як на керівникові якогось підприємства.
Поки 50-кілограмова Соня перекидає 100-кілограмового Александра запитую у голови клубу,
як оподатковується діяльність об'єднання. Виявляється, жодних податків так звані "ферайни" не платять. Як так?
Ми маємо визнаний державою статус корисного для суспільства об’єднання
без комерційної вигоди. Якщо податкове відомство це визнає,
платити податки не потрібно. Раз на три роки податківці перевіряють,
чи ми все ще некомерційні, тож ми маємо надати для контролю
інформацію про всі наші фінансові операції.
Звільнення від сплати податків - ось він, один із головних мотивів
для заснування сотень тисяч "ферайнів" у Німеччині.
Звісно, є й ті, хто зловживає статусом корисної для суспільства організації.
Останніми роками спалахнуло кілька скандалів про ухилення від сплати податків.
Наприклад, у Берліні члени гольф-клубу з понад тисячею учасників платили окрім внесків
ще й пожертви у 20 тисяч євро, які не обкладаються податком.
От такий дріб'язок на проведення вільного часу.
Безумовними авторитетами світового рівня, статус корисних для суспільства організацій
яких доведений багаторічною благодійністю є такі німецькі товариства
як "Червоний хрест" або "Карітас". Є і менш відомі, але важливі благодійні об’єднання,
які приносять чимало користі, приміром, у межах певного регіону.
У діловому кварталі Бонна, в одному з бізнес-центрів,
проводить свої засідання благодійне об’єднання молодих бізнесменів.
Wirtschaftsjunioren запрошує до своїх лав усіх, хто має свій бізнес,
ще не досяг 40-річного віку і хоче бути корисним суспільству.
Голова правління об’єднання у регіоні Райн-Зіг професійний маляр Тімо Троґ
та перший голова правління, власник IT-компанії Іван Кравченко обговорюють стратегію
розширення своєї благодійницької діяльності 2021 року.
Чим саме займається об’єднання, схематично пояснюють на дошці.
Ми є частиною загальнонімецького об'єднання "Молоді підприємці Німеччини",
який налічує понад 10 тисяч членів. Один із наших проєктів - "Підмайстер на один день"
у співпраці з підприємствами регіону. Ми даємо можливість молоді, яка закінчує школу
або з якихось причин не змогла закінчити школу, має низькі оцінки успішності
і через це не має жодних перспектив, на один день потрапити на виробництво,
аби зблизька ознайомитися з професією і все побачити зсередини.
Тімо та Іван переконані, що "важких" підлітків набагато легше зацікавити якоюсь професією,
просто запросивши на один день до виробництв, на які так просто не потрапиш з вулиці.
Є у цього об'єднання і спільні проєкти з іншими благодійниками, наприклад,
з Bonner Tafel - "ферайном", який опікується малозабезпеченими мешканцями Бонна.
"Віртшафтсюніори" протягом року з різних каналів збирають шкільні речі,
передають їх до Bonner Tafel, а Bonner Tafel розподіляє ці речі між родинами.
Перед початком шкільного року спілкуються з людьми, які купують речі для своїх дітей,
і просять їх купити на один більше - на один зошит більше, на один олівець.
Для однієї родини це може означати не такі великі витрати,
а для інших це можливість отримати добру освіту.
У 2020 році місцевим членам об'єднання вдалося зібрати до школи дітей
із двохсот малозабезпечених родин у Бонні. Цьогоріч планують розширити
свою діяльність на Кельн і Арський регіон.
Виявляється, у Німеччині жіночий монастир теж можна зареєструвати юридично як "ферайн".
Я приїхав до сестер католицького францисканського монастиря
у районі Бонна Рамерсдорф, які присвятили своє життя служінню іншим.
Мене зустрічає настоятелька сестра Катаріна. Їй 63 - вона наймолодша з шести черниць,
які залишилися у монастирі. Черниця проводить територією і показує комори,
гараж, просторий двір. Монастир 2020 року відсвяткував сторіччя.
Його реєстрація як об’єднання спростила для настоятельки всі юридичні формальності,
адже вона самотужки опікується і фінансами, і комунальними платежами,
і сплатою оренди і оформленням усіх документів.
У 1993 році був заснований наш ферайн. Ми маємо устав, у якому зазначено,
що наше об’єднання основною формою діяльності має піклування про літніх людей,
те, що ми здійснюємо душпастирство і робимо усе це безоплатно.
Раз на квартал вікарій з Кельна перевіряє всі грошові операції об'єднання монахинь,
тож у сестри Катаріни все акуратно відсортовано у папках, включно з кольоровими світлинами
показників лічильників води. Є чому повчитися берлінським любителям гольфу!
Черниці працюють доглядальницями у будинку для літніх людей, який розташований поруч.
Раніше він належав ордену, тепер перейшов у власність благодійного об’єднання "Карітас".
Орден францисканців у Бонні поступово зникає, тож настоятелька вирішила вчинити так:
Як релігійний орден ми зараз нічого не маємо у власності.
Раніше нам належала земельна ділянка і будівля старого монастиря.
Ми все продали для того, щоб мати фінанси на старість. Тобто з цих грошей ми тепер живемо.
Сестра Катаріна домовилася з інвестором-забудовником про те, що перший поверх новобудови
буде пристосований для життя черниць з капличкою і келіями і забезпечуватиме
легкий доступ для людей з обмеженими можливостями. Це житло ферайн орендує.
Дві з цих черниць на фото вже заслабкі, тож за ними доглядають молодші сестри.
Аделаідіс і у 81 рік готує на кухні сніданок для пацієнтів будинку для людей похилого віку,
прибирає у палатах. А це авто, на якому вона їздить на закупи для всіх черниць.
Я права отримала у жовтні 1961 року. Тоді Саарбрюкен ще був французькою колонією.
Після молитов та робочого дня сестри разом дивляться телевізор,
читають газети та обговорюють новини про коронавірус.
Друзі, ви коли-небудь розмовляли з "жовтими янголами". Виявляється, вони існують!
Саме так називають працівників технічної допомоги загальнонімецького
автомобільного об'єднання ADAC.
Ось такі автомобілі технічної допомоги курсують німецькими містами.
За кермом у них і сидять "жовті янголи" - німецькою "gelbe Engel". ADAC - найбільше зареєстроване
об'єднання у Німеччині з понад 20-ма мільйонами членів. Однак за структурою
це вже давно комерційна фірма, яка продає свої послуги, а відповідно - і  платить податки.
У цьому випадку від класичного "ферайну" тут лишилася лише форма.
За членські внески (а це від  54 до 139 євро на рік - залежно від бажаного спектру послуг)
працівники ADAC прийдуть на допомогу водію у разі поломки авто.
Я вже близько 25 років працюю в технічній допомозі на вулицях Бонна.
Монітор - замість диспетчерської. Ми вже не розмовляємо телефоном - все про виклик
з’являється у цьому комп'ютері.
Тут шухляди з корисним дріб’язком, як ось ця рідина, щоб відкрити примерзлі двері взимку,
кільця для шлангів та кілька запасних акумуляторів, щоб допомогти багатьом.
А ще кілька каністр з дизелем та бензином та навіть відмички для дверей.
34 відсотки тих, хто є членами німецьких ферайнів відвідують спортивні об’єднання.
Пропоную завітати до клубу веслярів німецького міста Бад Гоннеф.
Для жителів Рейнського регіону звична справа знімати стрес після роботи у будній день,
веслуючи у спортивному човні. Рейн не замерзає взимку, тож байдарки та каное
на річці можна бачити весь рік. Судноплавство на Рейні дуже активне, і веслярам доводиться
маневрувати між величезними баржами. В цю пору Рейн виходить з берегів,
тож застаю членів спортклубу за підтягуванням причалу.
За ніч вода піднялася і відірвала причал від берега. Голова об’єднання веслярів Аксель Тропп
бере активну участь у подоланні наслідків стихії.
Це об’єднання було засноване 99 років тому. Наступного року у нас сторічний ювілей.
У нас загалом 340 членів клубу. Для дорослого річний членський внесок
становить приблизно 320 євро на рік. Окрім цього, активні учасники клубу
мають відпрацювати 10 годин на користь об’єднання -  косити траву, фарбувати,
чистити територію, будь-які роботи.
Прямо під час інтерв’ю керівник клубу зривається з місця і біжить на допомогу.
Через сильну течію човен зі спортсменкою-любителькою перекинувся. На вулиці плюс два градуси.
Напарник жінки по тренуванню доставив промоклий одяг до берега.
Молодий чоловік тренується в об'єднанні вже 6 років.
Я намагаюсь поєднувати навчання в університеті і тренування.
Хочу тренуватися в тому ж обсязі. А в майбутньому мрію перейти на професійний рівень.
Завдяки активній роботі таких об'єднань юні спортсмени-любителі дійсно нерідко знаходять
шлях у професійний спорт. Це ще один важливий внесок "ферайнів",
не кажучи вже про популяризацію здорового способу життя.
Буквально за 5 хвилин після цього висока вода зриває другий причал. Здавалося б,
зима, не пік сезону, а у керівника клубу все одно гаряча пора. Далі йдемо до святая-святих
- місця зберігання човнів.
Членські внески та прибуток від здачі в аренду причалів за рік акумулюють 100-120 тисяч
на рахунку клубу. Ми можемо собі дозволити оновити один човен на рік.
Це орієнтовно від 20 до 30 тисяч євро.
Аксель Тропп - інженер. Його хобі - моторні човни, тож саме це привело його у "ферайн".
Робота керівником клубу - неоплачувана. А от відповідальність величезна.
Під його керівництвом клуб добудував до основної будівлі з човнами спортзал.
Це коштувало 430 тисяч євро.
Близько ста тисяч євро - це були гроші клубу,  решта - кредитні кошти.
Ми маємо виплачувати кредит протягом близько 30 років - це типовий термін
для кредитування будівництва в Німеччині. Звичайно ж, керівництво клубу не ухвалює
таке рішення самотужки. Все вирішилося на загальних зборах.
У серії про об'єднання землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія не можна не згадати про карнавальні,
бо саме в цій федеральній землі зародилася відома на весь світ німецька карнавальна традиція.
Цьогоріч через локдаун внаслідок пандемії коронавірусу карнавал під забороною.
Однак пропоную перенестися на це ж перехрестя рік тому.
Ось він, зірковий час членів карнавальних "ферайнів". Вони рік готувалися -
акумулювали власні внески та залучали кошти місцевих підприємців і на них шили костюми,
а декому вистачило і на нову тематичну пересувну платформу. Закупали солодощі,
аби тонами їх потім розсипати на голови сусідів по району та здивованих туристів.
Німці з надією очікують на повернення карнавалу, бо це означатиме повернення до звичного життя.
Шановні глядачі відеоблогу "Відкривай Німеччину", а що ще з життя німців вас цікавить?
Традиційно чекаю на ваші коментарі і пропозиції нових тем. Побачимось!